you disclosed a whole bunch of stuff
like personal like you were you know you
went through depression anxiety which a
lot of people on the show talk about
like zach levi has come out with you
know his mental well-being and and
stephen amell has come on and talked
about it i mean is that something that
you're comfortable talking about about
like you know dealing with depression
and anxiety and and substance abuse and
all that [ __ ] or is it something
no absolutely it's funny actually my mom
when i signed on to do heels my mom
called me and was like hey like i didn't
realize that stephen
has been open about some of this stuff
like that's crazy and like we've bonded
over that you know
um
like
i basically
went through like a really really rough
time and i mean it was bad it wasn't
like
you know like it starts off just like
you know you're hanging out with friends
and everything's fine and then you
realize that there's something like
inside of you that's you know
that you're kind of just trying to hide
and
um i ended up long story short like i
ended up checking myself into rehab for
like 50 days
in arizona and i just was like
i'm gonna lose my my career or even
worse my life if i don't put this
together and like i want to be a good
father and a good husband and a good
friend and i'll be none of those if i
don't get myself in check so that was an
incredible experience one of the
greatest experiences of my life um
and uh
yeah man it's been it's been a hell of a
journey and it's really crazy to be on
the other side of it i mean it's never
done but
um
having people reach out
now that are my friends or people i look
up to
uh for help and you realize just how
wide this is
i mean you know i lost a friend to
addiction
uh
six days ago
wow so yeah it's like you know you know
it was heartbreaking man he was 22 years
old and such a cute kid and it's just
like
there's no reason
why that that shouldn't have been me
and um because you were that bad
oh yeah yeah like i would go missing for
days and
like it was
you know i just think i had a lot of
demons i had to really
the hardest part is like i think
you
you medicate with whatever you have and
whether it's drugs or alcohol and
um
and suddenly when you get sober it's a
really scary period in your life because
what was your
higher power for lack of a better word
what you would turn to whenever you were
feeling
you know
down
or out um
it's not there anymore and now you gotta
actually like deal with these issues so
there's no magic i always tell people
who are like struggling with addiction
there's no magic pill like you have to
really want this like you have to really
want a better life but there is a better
life you know i've been sober for almost
four years and it's
it's um
it's remarkable how much the universe
can reward you in ways you've never
expected when you finally decide to love
yourself yeah that's the hardest thing
in the world i've talked about it before
is
loving yourself it sounds so
cliche and like you gotta love yourself
before you can love someone else but you
know it's it's [ __ ] true it's true
and it's hard to love yourself i mean
it's it seems like of course you should
love yourself everybody loves themselves
but like really answering that in front
of a mirror when you're alone
is a different story
and i've been i've struggled with that
you know i don't know you know i
definitely have my demons and
insecurities and thoughts of like
you know they're gonna find you out
you're not really that good you're not
really that you know and not i'm being
so hard on myself so lately i've lately
i say the last couple of years i went to
a treatment center too but it wasn't it
wasn't for substance abuse it was just
i felt like
completely lost
completely just lost and my friends were
all surprised when i said i'm going
someplace for three weeks and i just
need to clear my head and they're like
because i'm always the guy who organizes
sports and activities for everybody and
has people over the house and
they're like what
and i was like yeah i just got to do
this for me and it was amazing going
there because
it was cathartic as the word because you
go there and i i felt like nothing could
help me and then you start to talk to
people who you feel like really care
about you
and you start to let out these emotions
that you never thought you had
that you never thought things from the
past affected you and
it's kind of like clean and chop it's
like hey man i gotta take care of my
body it's like you know
mental health and therapy is just as
important as
working out and all these other things
they go hand in hand in a lot of ways
and
so i get it not loving yourself that's a
did you learn in those 50 days to love
yourself
i learned like tools that i think that
like
i think that
loving yourself is so much deeper it's
definitely something like it's an active
you know every day you know comes with
its own its own struggles and some days
are easier than others you know but um i
certainly realized what the issues
uh that were that were kind of
influencing this uh
this feeling i had about myself were and
and how
and and what i could do to kind of start
addressing